good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast
and have a happy
friday friday gotta get down on friday
everybody's looking forward to the
weekend
weekend friday friday
gotta get down on friday everybody's
looking forward to
the weekend party and party
and yeah party and party and yeah
fun fun fun fun looking forward to
the weekend happy friday everyone
we did it we did it you guys it's so
exciting
like it's here it feels so good thank
you for leading us
into the weekend in song it's what i
truly do best
it is what you do best and that's
probably the longest version of the song
that we've done
and it just really highlights like the
atrocity that is that song no it really
happened
fun fun look i really am like having fun
looking forward to the weekend how did
she know
honestly it's pretty on point um
speaking of on point
i'm bringing my hair up today which is
like as you guys know like a major
trauma point for me and i just wanted to
put it out there that i'm wearing my
hair up and i
just feel like people should be talking
about it i think that they should be too
and i just love that we're both
wearing our hair up we did not
coordinate and i just think it gives the
show you know that jenna sequoia
like oh these girls are so coordinated
yeah you know yeah totally and i really
also just wanted to update everyone i
know i sound a little hoarse but i'm
feeling better i've received a diagnosis
which
i think inherently makes you feel better
like totally i have a little upper
respiratory infection so nothing
crazy just something a quick z-pack can
fix and
is it an f-pack no is it
a g-pack no did an
h pack no keep going
is it an ipac it's a z
pack do you guys know what that's from
quevengenie wallace on snl
no kevin hart on snl in another skit he
does play
while it's confusing but is it an f
shirt
no it's literally the best snl he does
engineering and then he does this like
weird like nickelodeon
type commercial and it's like an inside
family joke i don't think it's regarded
as like a good episode of snl
that episode lives rent-free in my mind
when he's like up in the camera lens
is it an f sure the other guy's like no
it's a
z-shirt and you have to wait till the
end of the alphabet
it's such a good episode check it out
anyway she's on an
f pack i'm excited for her and also i'm
excited for you because i have a little
gift for you
oh my gosh that i'm going to be queef to
you it's actually you're going to be
queef
uh i'm just saying you're gonna queef
bequeatha
be queef another text another tick tock
joke would you like a queef in a pan
it's mon paw specialty what yeah i'm on
like a dark side of tick tock now
this girl um alina i think her name is
she does these like fake skits where she
runs a restaurant called mom pot's
kitchen
and she has these different specials so
she had a queef in a pan that like went
viral and then she offered another
special at her restaurant um like a
shart in a pan or something
yeah it's dark wow so funny melina's
number one fan though
um okay well i'm just the messenger for
this gift because it was gifted to me
and then one was gifted to you and i
just wanted to give it to you on the
show so as you already know and if you
follow me on instagram you know that i
had an influencer play date with
influencer sabilla cory
super jealous and we spoke about her on
the show a few weeks ago because i was
influenced by herself tanner and then
she messaged me because she's a toaster
and she's like oh my god dying they
talked about me on the toast and the
blue mascara
and so she brought me blue mascara i
noticed you were wearing blue mascara i
am wearing the blue mascara today
because i was like oh my god i'm going
to wear it tomorrow it literally looks
perfect on you
and she gave me one to give to you oh my
god
that is she's so nice crazy generous
right bad gal
bang benefit like so cool expensive
fancy i actually do follow her on tick
tock and i know that benefits sent her
like more than she ever knew what to do
with so i'm so glad she's getting she
found something to do with that hold on
giving them to us
can i try it on yeah it looks really
good on you i feel like my features are
like
too dark for it to show up do you know
what i mean yeah cause i put it on
my blonde lashes i didn't put on mascara
first and you redheads have like the
perfect
oh that's what sofia said so
let's see i'm also wearing mascara which
is not helpful
nobody oh it's definitely showing up
that's so cool i'm so severe
oh my god oh it looks really cool like
you get a little so sophia court
you really are is that sophia court i'm
co-hosting with yeah
two redheads all right well i'm just
going to finish applying this
because sofia court told me too dad
oh my god this is so generous is she
from the south
i feel like only people like from the
south bring gifts to lunches no she's
not though
but yeah she was very um polite very
sudden strack of her
very very i felt like the [ __ ] like
where's my totally like
you know toast merch yeah like come on i
can't i'm an animal yep i know
animal i'm almost done sorry but you can
keep talking
oh okay well we have a great show for
you today because obviously we have the
fastback stories that you
do need to know today um i'm obsessed it
looks really good i can i feel like i
can see a difference
and we have a lot of things to recap a
lot yeah we do i'm
99.999 caught up on love island except
for last night's episode so just bear
with me so i'm just gonna let you talk
about it because i'm so behind and i
don't know how i'm gonna catch up and so
you can spoil because everybody wants a
recap and like [ __ ] it
yeah and it's not like the biggest deal
and maybe i'll just like start from
where we are now because i've been
trying to catch up and it's like
there was a major drought before casa
and more like and are you still before
kazamore yeah
it was bleak and like casamore couldn't
have come at a better time okay so
you're just gonna let us know what
happened
i'm to just take your word of the gospel
i caught up on siesta key so i
must give my thoughts there and olympics
of course but that will be within the
past
because there's so much sunni sunni
sunni leaves
okay you don't know how to use the
triangle no you have to hold it by the
corner
yeah and you know actually i think i'm
missing a piece because
there's supposed to be something to hold
it
but if you put like a ponytail yeah yeah
it'll be fine i'm gonna leave it here so
i'm not always scrambling for my
triangle
totally like when you start singing i'm
like it's like that chicks
i'm familiar with that one yeah so like
that's really smart to leave your
triangle up there but i kind of like the
adventure
the thrill yeah yeah plus you don't have
like oh you have like if only your guys
can see
you're not squatting on your second if
you guys could see like our second
couches
yours is insane i clean mine up every
day you never know mine
is well no those are my cliff bars from
right before the show
i keep a water bottle my ipad i think
these are ben's airpods my phone
oh i have to return those to him should
i just give them to you
from your couch to mine all right try
come on
i'm trying trying oh my god
wow okay um should we just start let's
just dive right in there's a lot to talk
about and we just need to talk about
suny lee so without further ado
to do where are you five for five told
us to go [ __ ] ourselves this week
um it is time for the fast food stories
that you need to know before you wake up
and take a bite out of your morning
toast
do you think that zpack also cures your
rdh
i'm so sorry i got very nervous to tell
you about today's sponsor i just kind of
froze
no no you can't freeze on a podcast
no that wasn't good you can freeze on a
podcast and also i just wanna actually
i'll talk what whatever you didn't like
my skin
no because like for the people who
aren't watching on youtube they're like
did my audio cut out
right
you
okay i'll get into it please do honestly
you don't support
my like dreams and hobbies and it's
really just so not true i support you to
the
nth degree but i think part of being
support is being honest
oh now you sound like someone who calls
me fat and it's like you can't take
critical feedback
if you bring everything back to being
fat like i literally can't
i support you well you just call me out
hard i support you so much in life and
in your art
but also you can you know my support is
real because i don't just like falsely
support you when it's not good art
but
okay i'm just moving into the sponsor
like this is taking too long okay here
at the morning to
whoa whoa sorry
here at the morning toast you know we
love anything premium and today we're
here to talk tell you about the most
premium qr code on the market flow code
we've been seeing qr codes everywhere in
the last year but flow code is the
future of qr codes
backed by data and super custom design
which is so important because let's be
real
real regular qr codes are ugly as hell
now
you're probably wondering why on earth
would you be telling us that you need a
qr code but we know so many of our
fabulous toasters are business women
teachers moms with a side hustle
and that's worth we are thrilled to
introduce you to flow code because every
toaster needs a tool that gives you the
audience
that gives your audience the ability to
instantly connect offline and online
the best part is that when you sign up
for flow code you also get access to
flow page
the number one landing page platform
that helps you organize all of your
links and content
so if you have a small business in etsy
shop and instagram i use flow codes on
all my socials because i want a website
in my bio
that can link to my book that can link
to my other social media
tours my tour tickets for my tour then
also this is the company that helped me
build the clear the list
website so that you can really if you
don't know how to make websites or
you're not like super tech savvy but you
have a business and you know like how
important it is to have a website
with all your socials flow code is the
perfect place to do that
every and a lot of fabulous celebrities
use it too so like if jlo and reece
witherspoon
um are doing it like maybe you should do
it too and if brands like supergoop and
bmw
are doing it like you probably should do
so for 10 a month you can be just like
jlo
sign up for flow code pro with just 10 a
month and get access to unlimited flow
codes
10 flow pages and artist design code
advanced analytics and so much more
so what are you waiting for you can sign
up for flow code today at flowcode.com
pro for only ten dollars a month and
when you use the code toast you get your
first month free
that's f l o w c o d e dot com
slash p r o code toast for your first
month free free flow code
dot com slash pro code toast sign up
today
and get connected so if you have a
business influencer anything
get your hands on a flow code sign on
get flowing and coden
sign on it flows in town yeah um what i
was gonna say when you were being silent
on the pot
like when you were um frozen and like
that's just really not great for audio
you're just gonna critique me more nope
it was just a segway that reminded me
that last night i recorded
a patreon episode with zach and he was
nodding a lot of the time and i'm like
you must speak you're not that's so
amateur like
no it was fine though but i do feel like
every single time we podcast like every
three years
um that comes up and i'm like you're not
i didn't realize you're such a nodder
right right right very cameron wescott
yes we did um a deer toasters episode
where we went through some of the
patreon
deer toasters queries and we got both of
our advice and honestly we give
very different advice it's so funny
because i guess like where you and i are
very like
cut that [ __ ] out toxic yeah like we're
very cut throughout
we're i just feel like by the time
people are writing to us like they've
tried all the other avenues so i just
assume like you've gotta let go and let
god
and he's just like you know try it this
way try it this way intervention and i'm
like
okay cool so if you want to listen to
that all of you know the different
advice that we give head to patreon.com
morning toast it was a really fun
episode
and um we haven't heard from zach in a
while and he's doing well yeah i heard
he gave some hilarious
he did give him hilarious tips i was
like in shock
okay are you ready for our first story a
little olympics recap of the day
suny lee celebrates her gymnastics gold
with a dance party and pizza in her room
and pizza boy does she deserve it suny
lee has every reason to celebrate and it
seems like she's doing just that
lee who became the first hmong american
gymnast to earn olympic gold on thursday
night
in the women's individual all-around
posted a tick-tock video of herself
enjoying pizza
and a dance session after her victory in
the clip she's grooving around and
posing to a sped up version of azalea
banks's luxury
while showing off her new hardware and
wearing a team usa tracksuit she wrote
in the caption
on top of the world right now she ended
thursday's competition
with a 57.433 just ahead of silver
medalist
rebecca andrade of british who was
incredible
incredible i was really sh i mean the
scores make no sense to me i know
and um suny was everything but just
based on the performances i was like
this girl from brazil is winning i was
waiting for her to have like a really
big
mess up that like because we knew that
suny won so i agree i had the same thing
and that was the spoiler from yesterday
we didn't want to share which was that
soon he won the all-around she did step
out of bounds twice during her
routine that was that on that um and
then a russian
olympic committee's angelina mel nicola
who finished with a 57.199
yeah those russian olympic girls who
beat the us for the uh
team were not having a good night last
night like they were
bumping off the balance beam like they
were just i feel like they put all their
energy into the team
activity because they were just like
slipping up left and right and i feel
like it was really sad to watch but i
was super happy for suny so i was so
happy for suny she literally
just made our country so proud we said
it the other day like she put the
country on her back and what's so crazy
is she in her post
interview um she like sat down with nbc
but like outside it wasn't the one where
they're like
still like trying to catch their breath
in a mask trying to talk about how
they're feeling oh my god when they do
that with the swimmers i'm like leave
the swimmers alone
no like they're literally let them sit
down but also after they complete their
routine like obviously they've just done
like a
physical feet and then they go and put
their mask on like trying to catch their
breath
in a mask like i'm just like damn that
ain't right also sunny
like literally won gold with acrylic
nails i saw she was just like they were
so long like she looked so cute well you
got to be feeling your best self
she had eyelash extensions you're going
to be winning gold totally
totally totally um so
oh in her interview afterwards she was
saying that like after simone
um left the competition like she was
starting to feel all that pressuring and
i mean
literally put that pressure on her we
did we said we did we said
he's all we have left we said that's
what we said we said suny
turn around i'm getting on your back and
i mean so
like she came through for all of us
still with that pressure and i'm just
i'm so so happy and she was so happy and
then her family was there and they were
so happy there was 300 people
in her hometown watching together just
they had to move to a new venue because
so many people wanted to watch
i know like just the cutest i have
something story
okay and i'm really not trying to like
point fingers or anything
but michael phelps who's there as a
correspondent is there with his wife
what is her role right is there even
like one that they're saying no of
course i'm sure nbc could bring a
certain amount of people and that has
nothing to do with the olympics
so like it's just like sue nelly's
parents had to watch her no that's still
in minnesota
and michael phelps who's there doing
once a day corresponding
no gets to bring his wife i was so shook
because i was like stalking him on
instagram and i saw her i'm like
is this girl in tokyo it just feels
really unfair
no that is really unfair i don't like no
if she got the opportunity it's not her
job to say no because sunni mad
at the is i'm out at the system don't
hit the g the player hate the game
and again last night i was really
feeling like
the absence of family members parents
was keenly felt and these
these athletes like they're just not
okay and i saw that interview with caleb
dressel that you were he's not okay
he was not okay not [ __ ] okay and
i it just breaks my heart like they
should be there suny's parents should be
there they they keep
showing this package of like everything
that her family's business
had an accident and you had the balance
beam in their backyard and it's like
she just won gold at the olympics like
le they should have been there no and if
you think about it like what it takes to
be an olympian is
your family sacrifices so much
financially it is such a burden to train
your entire childhood
into early adulthood for the olympics so
it's a financial burden but then also
you have to move around if you find a
facility that you like
you don't have a normal life and your
siblings have to sacrifice everything
so for all of that to not even be there
like
it's so wrong no it's so wrong and of
course like it's out of
their control but like it just does not
seem fair no i i
it just really is bothering me i know
but
it is what it is and i'm just i'm so
proud of sudanese i'm
so so amazing and i mean the athletes
were really
so stellar last night and it was it was
a joy to watch
i pledge allegiance to the flag
of the united states of sun erica yeah
and to suny lee
for which he stands one nation under
sunni
indivisible with sunni licious and
justice
for sunni and justice for the girls
that's justice
for simone for the girls [ __ ] sorry i
made that
the jesus for the girls just to the
family i could i could literally go on
and on about who deserves justice
justice for the family members that
couldn't attend a hundred percent
justice for david foster and justice for
the family members who are like out
there watching at 6am
oh right right bringing all that energy
right you know there was also um
swimming on last night yes i caught some
of that so did i which was exciting but
they had the real huts but to
like break up the women's gymnastics and
put like an hour of swimming in the
middle just like hang on to some viewers
yeah and i thought that was really
classless yeah but
i mean yeah that's exactly what they did
and why they did it of course everyone
knew suny one they're tuning in to see
suny and
and 30 minutes before she's supposed to
win they put an hour of smith and we
would have watched swim anyway like
leave us alone yeah i wouldn't have but
um
but also like because there weren't that
many big races and
like the big peeps like caleb wasn't
swimming katie wasn't swimming
um caleb swam now did you not swim last
night
he did swim i didn't see him out
that's what i meant like it wasn't like
caleb got a gold oh my gosh
so and katie wasn't swimming we had the
other
well now she came in second place that
girl who came in first place oh my god
she was so happy it was chunky
no um south africa she when she realized
like she finished swimming and then she
looked at the board and i think
she realized she came in gold and she
goes she broke the world record
oh my gosh she was so happy she was
hugging everyone around her like they
were like it was the cutest thing
and the americans came in second and
third um yes they did and they
they seemed really happy too so let me
tell you ryan murphy not the creator of
glee came in second on a race
no he did not he came in like oh yes yes
ryan murphy but then
there's another american michael andrew
and i actually thought it was really
interesting michael phelps was
explaining how this guy has like a
totally different way of training
because like most
swimmers let's say you're doing five
laps you take it easy for the first
three and a half
maybe four then you kick it into high
gear for the last one
because it's not sustainable to be like
the fastest for all five yeah it's the
tortoise and the hair but this guy
michael his training
like method is speed speed speed speed
and i was so excited he literally came
in last
like he was in first the whole time
until everyone else like kicked it into
gear of course and he was literally at
the end of like no more energy
as i sat on my couch well that isn't
interesting
it's the tortoise and the hair yeah sort
of um so our official medal count
um for all the countries please it's as
follows
okay so we have 41 overall which is the
most but china has 40. so like they're
right behind us
and china has 19 gold medals only of 14.
we still only
that was certainly the same as yesterday
medals were one today
yeah because we were 14 yesterday in the
olympics like now it's night
and japan has 17 gold but they only have
28 overall so honestly ratio wise
japan is doing fabulously yeah totally
like they're going for gold
yeah and they're not interested in
anything else wow
interesting yeah thanks for that
that's scary like i'm just really
competitive for my country
yeah would you rather be winning in gold
or overall overall for sure but like i
want both
i know but say but like it's not looking
good for both so would you rather be
japan or us right i'd like both
okay good luck to you i want to be china
we have 40 which is only one less than
us and five more golds
yeah i feel that yeah okay well that's
your olympics recap
um did you know that you get paid
if you win a medal what do you how much
we talk it varies in different countries
and like in a lot of countries like if
you win a gold it's like a million
dollars
i believe like the most you get paid is
in singapore
and the least is in canada a gold medal
gets you 15 grand
and in america a gold medal gets you 37
000 and if you're part of a relay team
you have to split it that's also why in
america
if you want to be a college athlete
sometimes you couldn't
you could what you couldn't get the
medal because then you're getting paid
for being an athlete oh how stupid
like these are rules but that world just
changed right because
cdaa now lets them accept sponsorships
right
like god forbid they just pay these
[ __ ] athletes god forbid
that's so crazy that's so interesting it
just shows you like
who's motivated which countries like
really want want that medal
right and i feel like in america it's
not even about the money it's about the
glory yeah for sure but like the money
is nice too like of course like 37 grand
compared to singapore a million dollars
yeah canada should be ashamed of
themselves 15 000 how much
does japan pay do you know do you want
to look at
where did you find out these things
where i find out tick-tock
okay how much do you win if you win
a gold medal for japan olympics
here's how much olympic athletes earn
for winning medals
yeah i would be interested in hearing
other countries okay so singapore was
the most 737 thousand
wow and then what which country did you
want i want to know japan i want to know
china
10 45 000. i want to know china and
russia japan is 45
000 okay russia and what was the other
one
china are like not on this list i'm
looking at which is really annoying
maybe they don't disclose
let me just google for china
so interesting no isn't that interesting
here china olympic medal
most golds at any cost oh this is like
some weenie for the new york times like
trying to be emotional just tell me
i don't know okay okay i tried worth
looking into thank you
thanks for that interesting factoid you
learn something new every day you really
do you really do
are you ready for our next story are you
ready to wrap up the olympics for the
week
for the week yeah but oh my god is next
week the last week of the olympics
i guess so because it's like only it's
only two weeks oh my god
that's a lot to swallow that's i'm
worried about you i'm not going to be
okay like
every day all i do is watch the olympics
yeah even the boring sports
that's so generous like archery which by
the way is so interesting they deserve
prime time
i had a dream about archery last night
not this you were the
archers i was just arching stunning
yeah it was pretty did you get to the
games where shannon said her family runs
in archery
like no so like in love island they were
doing these games and she had to like
shoot a bow and arrow and she's like
literally my family
runs like an archery business she could
not get one single one in oh my god
that's really funny i just thought that
was interesting
okay ready for our next story lizzo is
debunking a rumor about herself she
denies this wild rumor that she killed a
fan by stage driving
she said she's so funny she says i've
seen a lot of annoying things about me
on the internet but the thing that
bothers me
most is this rumor that i stage dived at
a concert and killed somebody
like that rumor it's a lie first of all
i've never staged
in my life and she said y'all really
gonna put that on my [ __ ] name
like i know i'm big but [ __ ] i'm not
that [ __ ] big oh my god this video
her tone was
so funny and i didn't know what she was
saying and i actually have heard that
rumor before like said in joke form i'm
like that's not funny it's obviously not
true
but like i'm sure there are morons out
there who believe it yeah i never heard
this i only heard it with
the um the caveat that you know it's not
true so i'm glad to have heard it in
that way that's so crazy that this is
something that has been plaguing her no
and like someone probably just like made
it up once and it caught fire like
that's how rumors [ __ ] start
yeah so i'm glad that she's debunking it
because that just not should be
circulating and also she's saying it in
such a funny way
so funny and now you know she's so smart
because now that's the story like i'm
not even concerned with the thing with
the rumor
her response is so funny and like so
confident yeah that i just loved it
yeah no me too we love to see subs
debunking
rumors like crazy you know so many
celebrities have just like these crazy
rumors about themselves where it's like
you don't know where it started
it's so untrue but it just like follows
them no totally like leah michelle can't
read
right like avril lavigne you know died
and then came back as an imposter
jerry's still out on that but for sure
yeah for sure
so there are other ones like craziest
rumors i feel like celebrities always
get asked that like what's the craziest
rumor you've ever heard about yourself
yeah there's i would have to think about
it yeah like liam michelle camry that's
exactly
even though it's more of like a
conspiracy theory um that has yet to be
dispelled but still dispelled is that a
word
um you dispel a rumor yeah you do dis
ballet broomer i'm
so smart so so smart i have a story for
you next that i'm not sure if you've
heard about yet and so if i'm going to
be the one that's going to break the
news to you i just want to give you like
a bit of a trigger warning okay let me
let me take care of some business okay
you gather yourself
you gather yourself today's shocking
news is brought to you
by allied home allied home is a family
owned
manufacturer of quality crafted bedding
products designed to give you a better
sleep experience
with an assortment of pillows comforters
mattress toppers and more designed for
every type of sleeper
you can find your perfect bed here very
true my juve blanket is from allied and
it's premium zone
allied home offers high quality bedding
uses using strategically sourced
materials
part of the responsible down standard
allied home offers an assortment of
basic bedding as well as
specialty bedding perfect for those long
summer night sleeps
if you're a hot sleeper you could check
out their bedding lined climber rest
they use special print technology on the
surface of your comforter pillow or
mattress topper which helps regulate
your body temperature as you sleep
they also have a bedding line focused on
recycling called the renew down bedding
where new bedding recycles the down in
post-consumer bedding a large
contributor to textile landfills
allied home takes it down from your old
pillows and comforters and recycles them
into new pillows
and comforters using 100 post consumer
recycled
with over 100 innovative bedding lines
allied home offers a bedding set for
every type of sleeper
you can find your perfect slumber with
allied home bedding it's true i have the
um
the climate rest because you know i'm
such a warm sleeper but i'd like like a
big delicious duvet but i don't want to
choke
so my duvet and my pillows are all from
allied and they're all from the
climberest
line and it makes a true difference like
i cannot explain how much i love
sleeping in like
delicious pants but i just can't like
yeah and i wake up like choking and
drenched in my own sweat and then i just
shower in the morning and i hate
showering in the morning so
the climber rest is where it's at um
allied home wants to give toasters a
chance to try their
amazing bedding for themselves so they
have a discount if you use code toast on
your next order
that'll be twenty percent off if you use
code toast so to try allied home betting
for yourself go to alliedhomebetting.com
that's a-l-l-i-e-d home betting dot com
code toast for 20 off thank you for that
claudia
okay what's the news let me drink some
water hold on yeah cause i don't want
you to get all choked up
no promises all right hit me simon
cowell's competition series
the x factor will be canceled after 17
years it makes me really happy that like
you knew that this
would like affect me for a number of
reasons and
shall i count the ways but first the uk
channel itv confirmed the news and said
that there are no current plans for the
next series of the x factor at this
stage
the show was created by cowell and first
aired in 2004 through the years 445
episodes of aired
the last season hit the airwaves in
2018. it went on hiatus in february 2020
not sure if it would come back
and now they're letting us know that it
won't come back the series has launched
the careers of
several successful british musicians and
boy bands that you've heard of
such as one direction leona leona lewis
cher lloyd
little mix little mix little mix in
america fifth harmony yes
and that's it yeah i'm gonna look up x
factor
famous famous i mean i feel so deeply
connected to x factor
one because i grew up like really
heavily invested in watching american
idol which was a simon cowell show what
why is your mouth of gabe
um because olly murr's just came up to
you know that is i love him
so much and i'm wondering if he came
from x factor
also would you google i just searched x
factor famous
the most iconic x factor contestants of
all time my next question was susan
boyle from xfactor
yes or was she america's got talent or
britain's got talent
britain cowell but he's on that show too
he's always getting talent
yes cheryl lloyd remember her oh my gosh
she took the world by storm
remember all the things that you and i
did first
and now you're doing them with her
that's a good song
this list of the most 15 most iconic
we've already mentioned
oh okay um no it's really sad it's truly
the end of an era i feel like
voice competition shows like aside from
the voice which has managed to survive
like are just a thing of the past
i know people are more like getting
discovered now on like vine like
not fine you know what i mean like tick
tock yeah i'm sorry i'm stuck in like
2016.
um on social media like that's the new a
r and like
it used to be like you needed to get on
simon cowell's show and now it's like
times are changing we're getting old
times are changing i just want to take a
moment to thank x factor for all the
talent that it brought us and
namely between one direction and little
mix we have bops for life
b-f-l for life i just
so much of who i am has really come from
x factor you know
no one is if you don't think about it
you think like i am who i am because of
simon cowell no and mo
like so much of my composition as a
human being is made up of little
mix that's so true and
that would not be the case if not for x
factor and simon cowell so i just feel
like
credit words do it i also i love one
direction so much but i just like
wouldn't say that they're a part of my
personality they're part of yours
yeah no but little mix is a part of like
of who i am you know what i also think
is a part of who i am
the kelly clarkson performance piece by
piece when she was on american idol
pregnant and she started hysterically
crying
and even though simon cowell wasn't on
the show then he created american idol
so like therefore that huge piece of my
soul
that's true wouldn't exist i could think
if i could only count the ways
in in-house having cowell has personally
like affected me honestly
even though like we have grieved
them so deeply
fifth harmony when they you know that
round of x-factor when they go to the
judge's houses and like sing they sang
hold on impossible
you remember that song yeah it is
so stunning and simon cowan gave us that
as well yeah and now
if we're talking about american idol
contributions and part of my personality
like he tell me kelly
he also inadvertently gave us from
justin to kelly which is a huge part of
my personality
yeah no it's crazy he gave us carrie he
gave us gary
and that's a big part of my life too he
gave us reuben studdard who's
often overlooked often often
disgracefully overlooked
he gave us lauren elena who came out
with a new song today that almost
brought me to tears
oh my god lord elena i almost brought me
tears while i was doing my makeup i was
like this is not a good time lauren that
happens i have blue mascara
oh my god that happened to me yours by
andy grammer not related to simon cowell
but like literally had to turn it off
because i was doing my makeup
i'm sure in some ways related to simon
cowell if i could i'll trace it don't
give me five minutes
yeah no but like it's so true jennifer
hudson i mean who would you be without
daughter
no one nowhere nothing
without audrey there would be no morning
toast hundred percent
so like i just think what about i think
simon cowell gets like a lot of [ __ ] i
don't know why because like he like
takes advantage of his artists for sure
but we'd be remiss we would be
devastated and we'd be heartbroken
if we didn't acknowledge the cultural
impact the personal impact
that all of simon cowell's work has had
on me i mean those
two years in america where x factor was
on were some of the best of my life like
i think i talked about that
a lot like when demi lovato was on
britney spears was on ellie reed was on
like those were the days
yeah and you almost auditioned for it
and now it's like the
that door has officially closed i guess
it was always a little open like you
could go to the uk and audition
yeah it's closed slammed right in my
[ __ ] face yeah
yeah and so it's the end of an era and i
just like i feel like it's important
that we
commemorate totally so thank you simon
for everything
thank you simon name of today's episode
thank you simon are you ready for our
next story which i feel like really
personally
um related to yeah rick ross
has 100 cars but no driver's license
stop that's literally going to be you
take the lottery the rapper claimed an
instagram video monday that he's got 100
cars but no driver's license but he
suggested it's not as crazy as it sounds
he said but guess what somebody just
paid me 20 000 to put five of the cars
in front of something just to take
pictures for two hours
if i'm not pathetic oh my god read that
again
somebody just paid me twenty thousand
dollars to put five of the cars
in front of something just to take
pictures for two hours pathetic so maybe
it was like some sort of sponsored thing
and they just wanted like the cool cars
in the background or also
at like hotels there's even like shitty
hotels there's always like
lamborghinis i'm like who was the
lamborghini staying at this motel but
they definitely like rent nice
cars to have them be at the front of a
lot of places yes so his
garage boasts cars including chevrolet
bel airs from the 50s as well as
ferraris porsches rolls royces
tesla's may box and a bentley so he's
over 100 cars he has over 100 cars
and he doesn't have his driver's license
and i just i feel really inspired by
this story even though like
it is so important to me to get my
driver's license one day
clearly i don't want you guys to you're
running to do it no i don't want you
guys to think that i'm not interested
i'm very very interested and i look
forward to that chapter in my life
whenever it comes but just to know that
i could have a car and not a license
let alone a hundred cars no license it
just it gives me something to think
about yeah but you're also not rick ross
who probably has like four
drivers but why couldn't i be i don't
know we got to work a little harder we
got to work a little harder that's
we'll do two weeks more or less
that's the moral of the story that would
be funny
that would be to get a hundred cards
yeah right like don't mind us we're just
gonna double up all of our episodes
we'll be back at five i just want one
car yeah no same well i would want one
car and then one fancy car
the thing is it's like it's not even
about the car the reason why well you
don't have you don't have a car because
you have a license but the reason why i
personally don't have a car
is because where the hell am i gonna put
it yeah like that's the real burden of
having a car in manhattan
yeah because you could lease a car for
like 100 a month no but like one day in
life like i want to have like a car you
know that's like um
your everyday car like my minivan toyota
sienna
is that what you want i like being in
the back of a mini man i don't know how
i'd feel in the front
so true because you want to watch the
tvs and i just like i like the space
jackie like most people when they call
an uber and get a minivan like they
cancel and like get a nicer car
jackie literally waits outside like for
me i'm like today's my lucky day
truly i just find it to be such a
comfortable ride yeah um
but then i also want like a fancy car
from when i'm dressed up you know
of course with that and that would be
for dinner parties at the country club
and that would also be a convertible so
i can scratch that itch of course
you know of course of course dreams well
happy for rick ross
i'm happy for rick ross and i'm happy
how does rick ross have so much money i
feel like he's like
low-key like irrelevant well no no
and also like back in the day you know
when in his day making money
i thought like this was his day i
thought today literally if heather
mcmahon hadn't posted him on her story i
literally would have forgotten he
existed like
and then you would have just said the
story rick ross i'd be like who yeah but
then like i saw how they're like so i'm
on the golf course
right they saw that too she was like
reminder oh rick ross exists you know
yeah yeah so
i just need to know what type of
investments he made to stay completely
out of the public eye but still have 100
cars because that's the life i want
well maybe he's the ceo of maybach music
group
oh so he's more of a businessman beau
than a performer
and he's both that's see that's [ __ ]
smart yeah somebody better snatch him up
yeah he's a businessman beau with a
hundred cars had no license and no
license he won't stay on the market for
long
are you ready for our fifth and final
story which is also about a performance
a performer speaking of performance is
it the final story
it's the final story
[Music]
do
first of all that was really good like
we were in sync with our chiming and we
didn't even practice that
you know what i want to know how i was
in sync with you i was watching on the
monitor i could see oh you cheated
i was prepared i could see when you're a
cheater
pumpkin oh my god it made for a great
performance no it was excellent and
honestly my throat like hurts so i
didn't sing and i let you have it and
and i think i hit all the notes it was
perfection thank you so much well now i
feel um
ready to get into the fifth and final
story which is the fact that
lady gaga and the people
people magazine says that lady gaga is
sizzling in the first trailer for house
of people
you didn't want to say sizzling like as
your own words no because i
i felt mixed about the trailer i thought
yeah for sure
so the trailer for house of gucci just
dropped as did the posters which claudia
posted on our instagram and in
accordance with the new flow guidelines
the flow is on
fleek the movie is starring lady gaga
adam driver al pacino jeremy irons jared
leto salma hayek reeve carney and jack
huston jared leto is irrecognizable
recognizable it's directed by ridley
scott and it follows the story of gucci
fashion house head
maurizio gucci and his ex-wife patricia
reggiani
and the aftermath of his death after
reggiani hired a hitman to kill him in
1995. that sounds like a spoiler alert
totally this is the gym everyone knows
except for the two of us
it's a jimmy hoffa situation sorry for
the coughing i swear that's my last one
oh and maurizio gucci who um
spoiler is played by adam driver and the
ex-wife patricia is played by lady gaga
yeah that i figured oh okay
um so i live for lady gaga i'm obsessed
i really think she's like a true talent
i did not feel like her italian accent
was authentic at all like it was giving
me
community theater that's exactly what i
got to and i'm really
i'm so glad that you know she's such a
serious
actress now and like that these roles
are coming to her and this movie looks
like
it looks like it has all the makings of
being good but then it just didn't look
good yeah and you can really only tell
so much about a trailer so i'm still
gonna go into it with an open mind
but the accent really threw me agreed
and also adam driver is like
arguably the most serious actor of like
our generation right now
like up and coming like i think in he's
still academy award nominee that they
made that very clear while she's a
winner
and i just feel like he's at the
beginning of a very illustrious career
because his acting chops
are on supreme he's a he's an a plus
plus a plus actor like just talented man
and i do think in the face of that
the accent was silly no
it's silly do you ever think about how
all the things you just said about adam
driver
um are true and he literally started his
career on girls
right and so it's like that's how good
of an actor he is to
break out from that so true you know
because to put that behind him
the rest of those girls like didn't
no except maybe social mammoth she like
she was in the flight attendant like
she's done a few things okay cool
the rest of them like are just the girls
from girls right
and even the supporting characters like
but that's how much his talent just
jumped off the page
that's actually really true for him what
have i seen him even though i didn't
even
i didn't think he was that good in girls
just because i like didn't like his
character he was amazing in black lines
man
yeah and he's also in the star wars
stuff oh yeah he's
me oh marriage he was twisted in
marriage story but like
he was being such a good actor because i
wanted to [ __ ] knock him out like he
was being so rude to scarlett
um you also see scarlett johansson
assuming disney i did see that
basically because like her movie black
widow came out in theaters and on disney
plus and like i guess like
at the like both of those things were
not like a part of her contract or
whatever
and disney plus released a statement
just being like this is so insensitive
to do like given covet it's like it's
not scarlett's fault covet happened like
she's just
being a businesswoman yeah and i don't
know i stand with scar joe
okay i don't really care no me either
i could tell you didn't choose the story
so yeah like i don't
watch black widow like i don't i don't
know where i stand on the contract issue
like oh somebody had a really good call
because you know how a few days ago we
were kind of
guessing what kelly clarkson should do
to supplement her income because now she
has to give two hundred thousand dollars
to her loser ex-husband every single
month and she just needs to make up for
that money with like some easy work and
that's
kelly in a marvel movie like kelly and a
d-com yeah not d-com
dc dc comics yeah ddc universe
yeah that's disney channel original
movie okay
um no no she needs to be in a superhero
movie
okay or like a streaming service
something because like those movies just
like
you do one of them and you're set for
life okay i saw that yeah really great
call then i also saw something that said
the more money she makes the more she
has to pay him so it's
it goes up it goes up because she's
making more all right she's gotta quit
she's got it working just despite him so
what she has to go into
just to spite him what do you think she
should trim off her resume um
i think everything i can't choose she's
so good at all of that she's so good at
all that like she's so the voice needs
her
the tv show needs her the music
children's books need her the music
needs her which is
kelly oh my god bruno mars and um
anderson pack came out with a new song
today
called skate and it is so good so good
silk sonic
so oh my god i was like groovin while i
was doing my bun
i was i was really affected by my music
this morning because there's new music
she laughed she cried
it was new music that's right i was busy
getting
a throat culture um so those were the
past five correct those were the past
five feel as though you needed to know
them feel like you're prepared to go
into the weekend
chat with everyone about anything and
share some thoughts we have a little tv
recap that's brought to you by bruce
the most fabulous electric toothbrush on
the market and when i say fabulous i
mean very effective and very affordable
because some electric toothbrushes can
cost over 200
which is just insane because we all want
clean teeth but like my god what are we
made of money what are we
rick ross so the bruce is everything you
need because it's affordable and
effective it comes with six unique modes
to customize your brushing experience
it also has a battery life that lasts
four weeks comes with a magnetic
charging stand and a compact travel case
they also offer a subscription program
so you never forget to change your brush
head again
bruce will ship you a new replacement
head every six months so you're never
stuck using a worn down brush head
the design is super sleek they have a
modern aesthetically pleasing design
that comes in trend driven
seasonal colors and it looks great on
your bathroom counter get 15 off your
brush toothbrush kit and the refill plan
when you use promo code toast at
bruce.com that's 15
off using promo code toast at bruush.com
sign on get your oral health in order
all right you wanna tell me about siesta
keeper sure i'll start with siesta key
okay finally juliet is back on the show
she had to like take a few episodes off
oh she came back she stopped kelsey in
the face um but you know what it's like
juliette is probably i mean julia is my
number one
cast member on the show for sure and i
said this when she saw
kelsey in the face which is that when
she's on top she's the worst version of
herself she doesn't know how to like
handle things when she's doing well she
like just gets really mean and just like
not gracious at all and like she has to
be knocked down in order to like
when she's trying to come back and like
apologize and and realize that she did
stuff wrong she's really like
the best like she called kelsey after a
few episodes post fight
to apologize and like i thought her
apology was just so genuine and
heartfelt and like just that she was so
sorry that she behaved like that that
like that's not who she wants to be that
like she's so sad that their friendship
has like gotten to this point and like
you know and i could i could feel that
like so i and i
kelsey is definitely you know very
reticent to accept her apology and
that's totally her
place to do that she's the one who got
slapped not me um but i just felt like
from juliet like
i got what i needed from her as a fan of
hers like and a very
sincere apology um and now like in the
episodes where she was off she like
focused on her business so much whereas
when she was on the island she's queen
of the world it's sam's island
she didn't focus on [ __ ] she was like
drinking all night just hanging out with
her friends and like
not prioritizing her business which she
needed to do and then of course when she
gets knocked down it's like you know
that's when you hustle and you're of
course
you're more focused and determined and
then she put together this photo shoot
and she was like oh my god she was with
um
there's this woman i forgot her name
who's i guess like juliet's mentor and
like sometimes she like meets up with
her
and she was just like being so funny she
was it was just like a really cute scene
and julia was like
i booked a photo shoot like i'm not
using my friends as models like i'm
using real models a real photographer
like
blah blah blah and it was just like i
was like you know what at first i was
like you should use your friends like
they're famous and it's
pretty it's like the siesta key bathing
suit line but like no it should be more
you're right it should be more so like
she put together this amazing photo
shoot on sam's boat
and um some of the like pictures from
the shoot were like coming up as they
were shooting them you know how like
sometimes the editors do that yeah
and i was just like go juliet like and
then the clothing
the suits looked so i don't know if we
ever got an update you bought a jmp the
label bathing suit okay i bought it i
bought a jmp the label bathing suit i
wore it i didn't take a picture of
myself in it because i'm just like
not that kind of girl and i just like
wasn't like feeling my most
snatch but i loved the bathing suit i
thought it was great material and i
actually um
lent it to snitch because i think it
would look so [ __ ] good on her
because it's like baby blue
but i was so impressed it came very
quickly i was impressed with everything
from soup to nuts so
that's why when i've been watching this
i'm like i know j p the label pops off
and i look forward to seeing that
happening right
and so all of her designs are really so
cute like elevated and
great fashion great style and so finally
she's getting her [ __ ] together and like
she's someone you can root for again but
like why does she have to get knocked
down like why can't in order for that to
happen why can't you root for her when
she's on top like that's something
that she needs to i think that's a
maturity thing look inward
and and figure out how to be better when
she's doing better yeah that's annoying
that like you can only like her when
she's down
right like and i want to just be so
happy for her when she's up and i'm like
oh no she's going to ruin it something
bad's going to happen
yeah so then sam jlo asked her to move
in with him cute
after a year of dating and he's just
like so obsessed with her it's so cute
and she was at first like i don't know i
need time to think about it because she
like likes her personal space and every
time they get into a little argument she
goes to her own place
and it's like that i totally relate to
that but that's also like not how you
grow in a relationship
if after if you guys can't like coexist
after like arguing like
if by living together you'll push past
those things and you'll reach like a new
you know echelon of relationship so
spoiler
by the end she um she's going to move in
with him so i'm like really excited and
they're still going strong on instagram
so like i feel
really good about yeah and sam j lo like
i ship to the enemy too
um and i really i like his presence on
the show like i said like he's not the
most natural on camera but i just feel
like he's a a
serious steady guy and he's serious
about juliet like fabulous i
really hope that they get married how do
you feel like the show is
existing without like alex campos at all
i literally never think about him i
never miss him and when i realized that
he's gone i'm like so
glad he like used to cause all this
drama and he's like why are people so
obsessed with obsessed with how what he
thinks about them like this kid is the
biggest
loser like totally so it's so nice to
have him gone
chloe left the show after you know
sending this long video
and now she's back on the show and like
literally every scene
she's back on the show i think they
brought her back i think production must
have like begged her to come back
because
julia wasn't filming because of the
fight right and someone needed to bring
kelsey and julia back together and i
think
like they don't they thought chloe is
the one who could do it yeah and it's
just so funny in every scene where she
comes back she like
shaves off another like thing that she
said she was gonna be like
you know like in this latest scene she's
like you know i'm not jesus like
right right and then like i guess a few
weeks ago she said she was no longer
drinking and she literally gets pet
poured the biggest glass of wine i've
ever seen like madison is watching her
drink it like
and it's madison so madison is engaged
she just postponed their wedding because
wedding planning was giving her too much
anxiety i think like with copen and
everything
not like she loves ish it's not an issue
it's not an issue
it's not an issue yeah it's the fact
that like i think she was probably
getting a lot of [ __ ] on social media
for planning a wedding yeah that was
giving her anxiety
and she was like i don't want it to feel
this way like can be postponed he was
like i just want to be with you
i don't need a piece of paper blah blah
blah madison just like has it
she is just everything of the sort
cara's back and
i she's one of my favorite people she's
just so
on point like everything she says
everything she does i wish that her and
juliette like
i hope that they can get eye to eye
they're in a good place i want them to
be good friends
because she is just like so
like she just gets it you know also a
really interesting storyline came up
amanda who i love who has just become
like a a
mainstay on the show she started out as
like not even in opening credits and now
she's full-blown cast member and she's
such a good friend to everyone by also
being interesting and funny and so cute
she's dating this guy tate tate is a
tick talker like comedian
influencer i think he's like pretty
successful oh wait i need to look him up
just to see if i like know his face
tate what i don't know just google tapes
he has to keep it i don't want that what
i'm about to say
to the come up okay tate you can keep
talking no no but you need to be
listening because i need to say
[Music]
okay tate sweet yeah sure yeah i've
never seen this man in my life okay
so he's like an influencer he does like
really well and they have a really cute
relationship
and cara was shopping with madison and
she was like
have you seen tate's only fans and
she pulls up like always we didn't see
them but she shows madison like all
these pictures of him like nude in the
shower video
like all this stuff like noon
and they she they tell juliet and then
juliet tells amanda like in front of
everyone which was like kind of rude
like
take her in private and it turns out
amanda knew that tate had an only fans
but when he told her he said i don't
post anything nude it's just like
pictures you know in my boxers and stuff
like this
not nude so she's just like he [ __ ]
lied to me he
she was like he could do whatever he
wants it's the lie
it's never the crime it's always the
cover-up right so it was just really
interesting and now
so she told him like i don't trust you
like if you're gonna lie about small
stuff you also are gonna lie about the
big stuff like i'm not gonna be with a
liar
and so he's like trying to win her trust
back and so we'll see how that goes but
i just thought it was um
really interesting because i feel like
during deer toasters were always like
how would you feel if you know you knew
that your partner was like subscribing
to only fan stuff but it's also on the
other hand like how would you feel if
your
partner was doing only fans and i feel
like if that was their career like
you'd be so supportive but like for them
not to tell you and you to find out from
like
she hates friends from power to be the
one who found the pictures like
she was just pissed but she handled it
like such a mature adult which she is
and she's just becoming one of my
favorites
wow yeah well things on love island have
gotten
quite salacious because basically and
what you're seeing now it got like
really [ __ ] boring the only drama was
like cinco was like still
into cash cash is still into cinco but
like there's like nothing he's gonna do
about it so it's like frustrating
trina started to sense that and they
were like having conversations but then
they
got split up and went to costa more so
the where they left everything at
casamore was
kashay and corey were like we don't like
each other we're best friends go find
something they were match-ups
yeah what happened to florida oh you're
still not there no i'm nowhere
pretending to
fell in love with jeremy okay good and
jeremy fell in love with florida then
ariel vandenberg came and was like we're
doing a crazy thing we're cutting out
four people and america's voting
america voted amy and wes got cut out
even though they're a couple so they
left together and they're still together
in real life
wes was the new guy yeah i just met him
okay
they leave together and they seem very
happy together who the [ __ ] is calling
me like i'm in the middle of a podcast
then florida goes home
and they save um
jeremy and olivia which was shocking
because
olivia has been there since the
beginning and she had to break she's not
connecting
with anyone i just watch this guy slade
come in who like seems like olivia's
into him and he could be into her what
happens there oh
literally one day after slade arrives
he's like someone came up at home i have
to bounce
it was actually really sad for olivia oh
that is sad and like i love you like a
great guy i forgot who i was
advertising agency he owns yeah gone in
a second like and he was so [ __ ] cute
so olivia was like bummed about that
so olivia's just kind of like i feel
like it's not her time no i know she's
like been flailing and wait you're going
to die and what happens next
so cash and corey get matched up i
always say the ogs that's what like
the og save oh geez cash and corey are
matched up together as
friends and they both do whatever they
want in custom or
what happened to isaiah he got he got
sent home in that big cut too okay the
only people that got saved were jeremy
and
olivia okay you didn't but you didn't
tell me somebody's telling me flo went
home
isaiah went home wesson ate me west and
amy went home yes
so then everything's like going fine
cash and corey
jeremy is single right yeah jeremy
single
shannon and josh are great the torturers
uh kira and will are well send them home
because they're [ __ ] boring okay but
so here's what happens
so they go to council more okay kyra is
losing her god
damn mind i cause i'm more like sofa
clamped about what's going on
and you know what she has every right to
because this girl comes in whose name is
also flo which was weird
she is the most snashy girl all the guys
can't stop talking about like her body's
just different like it's just like the
sickening body
and all she wants as well now
i'm surprised i didn't hear more people
saying like she was very forward with
will
and dare i say like forced him to kiss
her
and at least in the beginning and he
said he was like talking to the guys
after he's like i felt pressure
and i think what he meant was like i
literally felt pressured to kiss her
like she grabbed me and i was like no
but the guy's like yeah you feel
pressure because kira and he's like yeah
no like
there was she was being really
aggressive okay and i actually think if
the roles were reversed it like really
wouldn't have been okay she was like
really acting crazy but then they start
to spin it like he's really into this
girl
and we're you you're left thinking like
oh man he's literally going to leave
kira
keira's losing her mind over at costa
more and he's making out with flow
but the whole time i'm just not really
getting the vibe that he's inter but
like the show is like he loves her what
is he going to do what is he going to do
after the reunion here's what happened
of course he chose kira but like he was
making out with
this girl and that's going to come up
tonight or last night or whatever
because i'm one is he telling her on his
own volition
i don't know we'll see shannon and josh
were tried and [ __ ] true like
so happy for them like really proud she
was the first one out and like honestly
they played like a shawn mendes so i'm
like i was literally gonna cry like it
was so cute
then cingo cinco had like
spoken with this girl leslie like kissed
her once but like it was really nothing
major and he could have chosen her just
like started fresh without this love
triangle
and he was thinking about it but then he
decided to go with trina either to let
her down
to break up with someone in that way is
so rude yeah so i think maybe he like
kept her just to break up with her
because he's still in love with cash
but cash met someone at casa moore this
guy charlie who's
so obsessed with her and they're so cute
she did say them she's like it's very
open-ended with cinco so like i'm
bringing you but i want like i'm not
gonna be like a piece of [ __ ] like
there is still something there so like
and he was like i don't care like i'm
obsessed with you
like yeah so [ __ ] cute like obsessed
so
i kind of want her to just like stick it
to cinco and stay with this guy charlie
because he's
just as good like he's so cute yeah um
will chose
kira um but there's gonna be a bumpy
road along with them and then jeremy
chose this girl jenny who was new from
kazamore
who's the girl that shannon knows and
there's something weird between shannon
and this girl
and this girl's so annoying like the
fact that jeremy like i'm so done on
jeremy like
i'm just finished with him like he's an
unbelievable loser
and if you look at his instagram like
you'll understand what i'm saying like
he's just not who you thought he was
do you know what i mean yeah no i didn't
look for that reason and i trust
shannon's judgment and she doesn't like
this girl jenny this girl jenny used to
be friends or is still friends with
shannon's little sister
uh and she came in being like i want
josh like i know shannon's with josh
really that's your sister your best
friend's sister yeah there's just
something weird about her
and of course josh didn't even look at
her once but like in one of the games
they did have to kiss which was like
awkward
um but she was really happy with jeremy
from like day one and like i think they
were just like happy to be
like with someone yeah i don't think
it's the greatest love story of our
generation he's like still
like he was not okay when florida left
and he still hung up on florida
and speaking of that like and you didn't
even mention her it just shows how
irrelevant she is honestly olivia
oh oh thank you i think anyways for
getting someone so she was so excited
for casamore because she's like you know
what this is what i need like i haven't
connected with anyone
i've really been putting myself out
there she tried so hard to make it work
with giovanni which she should have
because he was
everything of the sort she goes outside
more
she's like vibing with people during the
coupling ceremony she comes back
alone she didn't bring back anyone she's
like i'm gonna stay single in the house
and then wait you're gonna die i'm so
mad they should have sent her home
in the previews for the next episode
which aired last night
you know what she does she she goes and
has a conversation
with corey and she's like
i think it's been you this whole time
and he's like what and cory's actually
in a really good place because a lot of
these new girls
were like really into corey this one
specifically like she was
literally so freaky like she was gonna
like kill him in his sleep this girl
isabelle he didn't choose
these girls coming to casa amor just so
hot they need to get that spot in the
house so the only
girl besides jenny this girl leslie who
a lot of people are into she actually
seems cool i like her like i think
she'll jive with the girl as well
um she was really into cinco and then
corey chose her and i think she really
wants to be on the show i don't think
she wants to touch corey with like a
10-foot no but like
and now cinco has like another girl for
his yeah
i didn't think it was that serious with
leslie and cinco but that's i think like
what they're trying to do
yeah wow that's crazy okay i'm gonna
just start watching from
from now watch last night's episode yeah
and then i'll and then tonight
yeah i just i had like six episodes and
i just and they were so boring for a
while
yeah yeah yeah okay no now it's in a
really good place when olivia had the
the house
come back alone if i were to watch this
sending home
thing where they chose to keep olivia
and central it was nice because
they're all friends but like florida had
multiple connections she was really bad
cory and jeremy were literally depressed
when she left like
crying in their beds like why the hell
is olivia still here i don't know
that's not right that's because there's
no connections with anyone yeah and she
had her
chance and she literally met five new
guys at casa moore and didn't take any
of them
so how many guys have come through so
far 12 right 15
totally it's it's just not your time
agreed
she's a san francisco 49er it's not her
time
so there's i'm gonna watch last night's
episode there's an episode tonight and
then sunday maybe we'll
regroup on monday yes and speaking of
monday next week scheduling update
so next week monday tuesday wednesday
podcast only episodes it's
because of me so like don't yell a
claudia you can yell at me if you need
to yell at someone but podcasts only
they're going to be fabulous and um i'm
excited and then thursday friday we are
off
always plan to be off off so just shows
monday tuesday wednesday and
podcast online podcast only and as
always if you want more content from us
patreon.com
morning toast um super premium content
this month we did a lot of podcasts if
you need extra podcast audio listening
to
head over to patreon and then um next
month we have some fun stuff as well
thank you so much for listening to the
morning show wow that was just like so
well you have anything else to promote i
don't know i just felt like we could
like
talk about our feelings i'm feeling like
my throat hurts and i want to wrap up
the show okay
i'm just going to miss everyone but
that's on me 100 percent of you
i'm i'm booked and busy and that's on me
and i'll just be here you guys thank you
so much for sitting to the morning toast
to the millennial morning show where we
live with the festive stories that you
need to know every monday through friday
on youtube so if you're watching this on
youtube please feel free to subscribe
and give this video a thumbs up
we're also available as a podcast pretty
much anywhere podcast can be found so
it's spotify itunes stitch or public
radio i everybody catch box all the
places
swiping listen podcast five nights one
until sleep if i starve you about a
beautiful setting smart we are
the society season two leave a picture
of an emoji
uh of a turtle on our instagram for
today hope you guys have an amazing day
we'll see you on monday goodbye